an ideal solution would be semantic and
it would validate properly wouldn't
require javascript or server
configuration necessarily it would only
load one copy of the image and it would
work across all browsers and be
accessible
unfortunately that solution doesn't
exist today there's several solutions
under discussion right now it looks like
the end solution will be some version of
the picture element
hopefully this will be hashed out in the
relatively near future so stay tuned to
the standards community for more there's
a link to the responsive images
community group in the instructor notes
in the meantime though let's take a look
at some other solutions